(box thudding on ground)
- (sighs) God, I can't
believe we're moving.
- Yeah, a lot of good times on that porch.
(harp scale music)
What the, how the f, how do you-
- You are impossible!
- Carve this thing?
This is bullshit.
(door closing)
- Okay.
God, crap.
Okay, now we're gonna
have to make two trips.
- No, not two trips.
- Hey, how much for the masterpiece?
(game show music)
- Ah, I fuckin' love yard sales!
- Mm hmm.
- This is my elementé.
- Oh, okay.
- They used to call me the el Closer.
- No they didn't.
- 'Cause I close every deal.
- Oh my God.
- Yup, I'm unstoppable.
- Yo, how much for the painting?
- 300.
- 300 eh, that's a good movie
but how much for the painting?
- 350 now because you
said that stupid ass pun.
- Oh yeah, he hates puns.
- Halloween's coming up,
and I was thinking of
a couple costume ideas.
Jumanji, it's kind of like a Jewish
explorer vibe sort of thing.
We could do a where-wolf.
Like where, like, I don't know!
I've got a map and I'm lost.
A snarky baby that's handsome,
maybe like Osh Kosh Daniel Tosh.
(bushes rustling)
Or, um, I mean, we could keep
brainstorming, obviously.
(dramatic music beat)
- 200.
- 325.
- Throw in the baby with boxing gloves?
250.
(dramatic music beat)
(dramatic pause)
- Deal.
Drive a hard bargain, sir.
(doll baby giggling)
- Here you go.
(doll baby laughing)
- How much was that for real?
- Like five, maybe ten dollars.
- Yo, that's the game, Kate.
You gotta highest ball it every time
so that when you come down,
you still win, y'know?
- Okay, yeah.
- Try it on this guy,
try it, try it, try it.
- Okay.
- Hey, how much for the lamp?
- One million dollars.
Shit, shit.
- Nooo.
- Yeah, went way over.
- Come on.
Uh, four hundred.
- Does it even work?
- Mm hmm.
- I need to know.
- It works.
- I need to know if it works.
(intimidating whirring)
- Okie dokie, I think we
have a plug in the back yard.
I could show ya.
Just follow me.
Are you good out here without me?
- Uh, yeah.
I think I got it.
- Hurtful, that was my
first time haggling, okay.
- [Male roommate] It shows.
- Right this way, sir.
This must have been out here since
last year's Christmas decoration disaster.
(Christmas music jingle)
- Hey, focus, I don't have
any time for your stories.
- Sheesh.
- Come to papa.
(switch clicking)
Maximum.
Minimum.
(switch clicking)
Maximum.
Minimum.
(switch clicking)
Maximum.
Minimum.
(switch clicking)
- Never met someone I
couldn't sell to (muttering).
(Western standoff music)
(horse whinnying)
- Hello.
(happy music)
- She's too adorable.
(girl giggles)
So, what is it that you, what do you want?
What do you need?
- Oh, I'm just looking for some materials
for these dolls that I make.
- Oh my God, of course you make dolls,
look at you, you're so adorable!
(happy whistling)
- Oh, how much-
- Take it, free, it's
fuck, fuck shit goddammit.
Fuck.
(switch clicking)
- You know, this one Christmas, I-
- [Man] Shhh.
(switch clicking)
Maximum.
Minimum.
(switch clicking)
Maximum.
Minimum.
- Just don't look at her.
You got it.
Sell her the stuff.
Don't look at her.
- How much is this throw blanket?
- Two hundred dollars.
(bass guitar riff)
yeah, nailed it.
- I only have ten dollars.
(bass guitar riff)
(girl crying)
- Minimum.
maximum.
(bird cawing)
Minimum.
Maximum.
- Derek's in trouble.
(revved up music)
Okay, enough. (gasping)
Derek stand back.
And you, your charms don't work with me.
- I donate to Greenpeace.
- Oh, save it, we all
donate to Greenpeace.
You're using your powers
for evil and you know it
so either you pay si,
uh, $750.00 for the lot
or try your best to get this
all on sale at Anthropology.
(dramatic music)
- [Man] Minimum!
Maximum!
- What's it' gonna be?
- Fine.
- Thank you.
Pleasure doing business with you.
Love your dress. (laughing)
Got her.
Mission accomplished.
(soothing music)
Alright, GPS set.
Say goodbye to this house.
- [Female roommate] Bye house.
(soothing music)
- [Male roommate] Home sweet home.
- [Female roommate] Doodle de do de doo.
- [Man] Oh, it could be a giant shrimp.
With a mustache, you'd be like, he he.
Prawns wants in, and that's, oh, God.
(wife laughing)
What!